hi i'm alexis and it's no secret that i
love burgers they're so indulgent
they're crispy they're fatty they're
juicy they're cheesy it's all the best
flavors in one i'm gonna show you how to
make a three minute burger 30 minute
burger and three hour burger because no
matter how much time you have you should
be able to eat an incredible burger
let's get to it
say you want a burger but you have no
time this is the burger for you it's a
three-minute smash burger one of my
personal favorites i'm using a blend of
80 20 ground beef i'm gonna shape it
into four even balls so once the meat is
divided you can season just on the top
with salt and pepper you can be pretty
generous here it's gonna form this
really nice crust don't worry i'm gonna
season the other side but once they're
in the pan that's really all the prep
you need to do so right now i'm ready to
make my burger i'm gonna heat my pan
over high heat at the oil while my pan's
getting hot just gonna toast the bun you
don't have to toast it but it adds a
little flavor i personally like a
toasted bun ooh
happened so fast so once the pan's super
hot like smoking just like this gonna
take one of these little meat guys
place it salt side down in the pan
working super fast take two spatulas and
just smash smash burger
and then season with salt and pepper
so after one to two minutes once it gets
this like really beautiful crust it's
called the mired reaction which is
basically a chemical process which is
the browning of meat mired reaction
gives me flavor it gives that brown look
covers your room and smoke it's ready to
flip now so
one felt swoop
ooh baby put your cheese on top once the
cheese melts your burger's done that
easy whew she's smoky
i mean this is the easiest burger ever
we got the burger we got our cheese
pickles ketchup
mustard burger in three minutes
oh
yeah you get this crispy craggy edge and
it's like salty and you got the pickles
for some acidity
it's so good this is it i'm done
screw the other ones this is amazing and
it only took three minutes so say you
have a little more time it's a weeknight
you want a burger you don't want to have
something basic you want something a
little more that's where this burger
comes in i'm going to start with pickled
red onions which are really easy to make
you can keep them in the fridge for a
few weeks and they're really going to
amp your burger up i'm going to start
with water
i'm using apple cider vinegar but you
could use champagne vinegar or white
vinegar you can experiment i'm going to
add sugar salt i like to add some
peppercorns and some coriander seeds i'm
gonna bring the brining mixture to a
boil as i stir i want the sugar and salt
to be dissolved so now that my brine's
at a boil i can actually
take it off the heat add the onions
and just make sure that the onions are
fully submerged i'm gonna let the
pickled red onions sit for about 30
minutes they're going to cool down so
i'm going to move on to making my own
thousand island dressing yeah you could
go out buy a whole thing of thousand
island but this is going to be about a
billion times better first mayonnaise
ketchup
garlic
some chopped pickles and vinegar and you
just whisk to combine it's that easy you
have everything in your fridge to make
this now it's patty time
add salt
add pepper
and mix it together i'm going to do a
pub style burger so smash style burgers
use about four ounces of meat where a
pub burger would use about six to eight
so significantly bigger if you take your
thumb and press it in the middle of the
burger and kind of make a divot it'll
help that the burger doesn't puff up as
you're cooking it it'll make a more even
surface
this is ready to go so i can start to
cook it off i'm going to heat my pan add
some oil like the smash burger i'm going
to toast my buns pan is hot time for my
burger
the smash burger cooked really quickly
for the pub style burger it's a lot more
meat it's going to take four to five
minutes before i flip even though i'm
not smashing it down with the spatulas
it's still going to get that beautiful
crust that mired reaction so once the
meat starts to color you can see half
way up it's starting to get brown that's
a really good indicator that the
burger's ready to flip
oh baby
cheese on top cook for a few more
minutes
that's a burger
oh the cheese time to build this burger
so i'm starting with the burger oh my
god it looks amazing add some lettuce
tomato some pickled onions and that
thousand island on top
damn
that's a burger
first thoughts are just utter excitement
i mean this looks absolutely insane
oh my it's amazing
30 minutes magic i i'm overwhelmed
it's crazy that it could get even better
than this there's a three hour burger
after this and it might put this to
shame i love you it's okay
say you have an entire afternoon and you
really want to impress someone this
three-hour burger is a real show-stopper
i'm starting off with making my own
brioche for buns so i've got warm milk
warm water
sugar
mix
and sprinkle the yeast over i'm gonna
let my yeast bloom for about five
minutes it'll get really bubbly and
foamy that's the sign that it's ready to
go so while that's blooming i'm going to
mix the flour and salt
just mix it up
oh okay my yeast is bloomed and foamy
i'm going to add the milk yeasty mixture
and get it just combined the dough is
starting to get really shaggy so i'm
just going to add the eggs the dough is
going to look kind of wet and all mixed
up it's going to look wrong but that's
okay you want to add the butter
tablespoon by tablespoon so that it
gradually gets incorporated into the
dough and is more cohesive now i'm just
going to let this mix for eight minutes
you'll know the dough is ready when it's
taut and forms into a ball that goes
around the dough hook now it's smooth
it's springy it's cohesive i mean look
at that beautiful dough perfect i'm
gonna put it into a greased bowl this is
gonna help prevent any sticking later
i'm just gonna cover it with a towel i'm
gonna let the dough rise for about an
hour until it's doubled in size that's
it for step one i'm gonna move on to my
caramelized onions they take a while but
it's something that's really really
worth it if you have the time going to
add my oil
and onions
onions are a classic pairing with
burgers i think caramelized onions are a
really nice addition because they add
this depth of flavor caramelized onions
take at least an hour if not more so
just going to give it a bit of stir
season them with some salt the salt is
going to draw out some more moisture too
that's what we want my onions have been
caramelizing for quite a while now and
they're starting to get cooked down i'm
just gonna add a bit of wine it's just
gonna add flavor and a deeper color the
onions need a few more minutes and
they'll be ready to go okay my dough
has doubled in size it's smooth it's
beautiful it smells yeasty just turn it
out onto a clean surface you could also
use a scale to measure these evenly but
i think you can just eyeball it
these are roughly the same size once
you've divided all the dough up take the
edges of the dough and you're just gonna
bring the sides together just like a
little package and kind of fold it into
itself it's so cute
so you've tied everything together
smooth
and then you can just put your hands
under the dough and kind of twist it to
bring it together
so you've got this beautiful little
round ball
i'm gonna squish it down into a disc
i need to let these rise for an
additional 30 minutes and then they'll
be ready to bake so while the buns have
their final rise i'm gonna finish up my
caramelized onions
these onions have been cooking for a
long time and let me tell you they are
caramelized this is how caramelized
onions should look
they're not pale golden they're not
golden brown they are dark and
caramelized they take time they take
patience but it's like it's like gold
you now have gold and now that they're
done i can finish up with my buns and
move right along my buns have been
resting and
they're ready i feel like a proud mom
i'm gonna do a little egg wash egg
water
you wanna make sure to brush the buns
all the way to the bottom because
remember they're gonna rise in the oven
so if you don't do that the top half
will be beautiful and the bottom will be
less so
my buns are egg washed ready to bake i'm
gonna pop these in the oven and move on
to the aioli you could just use mayo
sure but if you have time why not make
an aioli it's even better if you make
your own it does take practice and it
takes patience but once you know how to
do it
you can make it in like 10 minutes so
i've got two egg yolks adding some
grated garlic little dijon mustard
and give that a whisk
so this is the part that gets a little
tricky i've got some grapeseed oil so
i'm gonna start by adding just a drop so
you're basically adding drop by drop of
oil until an emulsion starts to form
it's gonna get thick creamy it just
takes a little bit of time to get there
when people say they don't like
mayonnaise i am personally offended
because i love it but more so i just i
wonder like if you like eggs and you
like oil that's all mayonnaise is
i've used almost all of the grape seed
oil and you can tell that it's starting
to get really thick it becomes pale
yellow it's kind of gloopy if you start
mixing like this is exactly how it
should look so at this point i can just
gently stream in the rest of the oil
so all the grapeseed is added adding the
olive oil you could do it without but i
think it adds a nice
little something
she's thick how many seas probably four
seas once the aioli becomes emulsified
you can add more oil at once you don't
have to do the drop by drop i can add a
little bit of pepper a little salt
and i'm going to add lemon juice that's
going to thin the aioli out a bit it's
also going to add some acid
this is like luscious luscious aioli
aioli is done and we can start making
the patties so the last step is grinding
my own meat which i know seems extra but
this is a three-hour burger this is
worth it the general rule for burgers is
that it's 80 lean 20 fat and you can use
all sorts of different beef combinations
to make that up i'm using chuck
sirloin and short ribs before i get
started it's really important that the
meat grinder is frozen and that the beef
is frozen otherwise it's not going to
work and it's a huge food safety risk
pop it on meat
and use this handy thing to just push it
down
feels great it's so satisfying
that's it you know another thing about
grinding your own meat is that the
patios are gonna have more air and more
juiciness than if it's already this like
pre-packed thing from the grocery store
it's really really worth it i'm just
gonna toss it together so everything
gets incorporated i'm gonna add the salt
pepper
and mix it all together
it's cooled now i'm just going to shape
them into their final shape
standard burger
nothing too crazy i'm going to do the
same divot in the middle that i did with
the 30 minute burger
that's it burgers are ready they just
need to be cooked up and assembled you
can tell the difference with the hand
ground meat it's so red it looks so
fresh i think this alone is gonna really
make this burger stand out i'm gonna add
my oil
and this is my beautiful bun it's just
golden it's light fluffy looks like a
pillow just gonna toast the buns like
i've been doing three hour burger needs
toasted buns
beautiful so beautiful wow pan's hot
smoking same process
okay
burger's ready to flip
oh
gruyere on top
let that get a little melty
i'm so excited for this burger
my burger's done the cheese is melted
it's time to assemble
this is the crown jewel of all the
burgers i'm going to start off with a
bed of arugula something to cut all the
fat
burger gonna add some aioli to the top
of the bun
oh my god and
using my fingers for some of those
onions
okay
moment of truth right they're getting
bigger every time
this isn't a burger this is like a steak
this is like filet mignon on a bun it is
so rich so decadent absolutely
incredible i mean the aioli the
caramelized onions the bun everything
feels so intensely flavorful it's
amazing it's amazing i wish you could
taste it i love all of these burgers
whether you have a few minutes and you
want to go smash burger route if you
have a little bit more time you can
really elevate it with a 30 minute or if
you have an entire afternoon and want to
make a very ambitious three hour burger
no matter how much time you have there's
a burger for you let me know your
favorite burger in the comments below
until then happy cooking
oh yes
[Music]
you